on this final episode of the year of the
askgaryvee show I talked about the Jets
Scooter Braun and cloning myself you ask
questions and I answer them this is the
askgaryvee show
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 58 of the askgaryvee
show before we get into the questions
this will be the last episode of the
year because tomorrow I go away with my
family two weeks off the grid
Subic said actually and I just told
Steve fortunately couldn't finish
everything this is ultimate hustle
Monday while in Mexico the way Steve
says it I don't have to do some hours of
work but in the garyvee show world 58
that's what we got under the under the
gun in 2014 it was a good run we started
when I don't know help me oh yeah August
thanks j-rock not bad did a nice job got
a nice number that's actually going to
be the question of the day what is your
prediction for the amount of shows we
execute in 2015 we'll make this like the
almond thing if anybody gets it right
actually no no I'm not doing that it's
not gonna be that hard somebody would
definitely get it right so I'm not doing
anything there's not the question of the
day let's go into the show
Echo's asks when you're working on a
project with clients
how much is done online like Skype
versus in-person meeting hey coach I
can't speak for the whole you know
vaynermedia team and I think they're all
individual but at my level or what I do
not even probably probably not
predicated my level just the way I roll
when I think about the client stuff that
I do you know I would say ten percent on
text 40 I'm not actually I'm not gonna
try to make this round out to 100 let's
see it probably is predominantly email
solid amount face to face I'm a big face
to face kind of fan almost non-existent
phone and growing because I'm pushing
them into more text so face to face is
probably 25% the rest is digital no
Skype or Google Plus you know any of
that kind of stuff I'm just uh I'm
predominantly face to face emails number
one face to face texting
and that's that no GoToMeeting the limit
Eric asks do you watch your own videos
Eric the answer to this question is no
it's funny Steve was just going through
the questions
d-roc was like no because he never
watched a full episode of the askgaryvee
show or any of the 1089 wine videos I
made a thousand Wine Library TV 89 daily
grape oh by the way this is gonna pass
daily grape at some point pretty soon
how does the fun fact that I have
actually had three I always say have two
shows it's actually three uh anyway
sorry me and Steve learning a little bit
about wine the answer is I don't I've
watched some of my video stuff because
I'm showing somebody some stuff I was
Mike now the d-roc Stephan are in my
life they make me watch edited things we
have a big new edited video up today
sorry Dirac I guess we decided we're
launching it today
so now I have actually seen some of my
longer form stuff because I have to like
look at it cuz it's edited but I know
what I do on the show I'm living it so
no I don't watch the show
Glen asks can you elaborate on what the
middle is why it sucks glad this is a
great question you know to me the middle
is the commodity work and thinking that
everybody else does
meaning it's what the markets doing
right now like it's it's one startups
push me we're gonna do something in the
photo app space
you mean like everybody's been doing for
the last five years it's its commodity
work you know I think that if you're not
trying to break things you're not doing
a good job or back to clouds and dirt
non-middle if you're not doing like you
know so funny I've sat through four
pitches today and I've liked two and one
is because the two guys are just doing
the work they're like in the weeds
they're not doing the big holistic
branding thinking game-changing stuff
they're just executing but at a raw
level I just find that there's not that
many hardcore practitioners and there's
even less big where's the world going
you know one of those friends at the
highest level or am i doing the kind of
things at the highest level and so I
don't really know how to explain the
work but you're surrounded I'm sorry I
don't really know how to explain the
middle but you're surrounded by it 99.9
percent of your life hey Gary I have a
question for you for a scary V who cares
about that question Gary this is more
important question how are you if you
were the owner of the New York Jets
gonna turn around this team and make us
a Super Bowl contender because we both
know that's all that matters and he's a
Giants fan who gives a [ __ ] what he has
to say good thanks Brad and scooter for
the question you know I mean the true
answer to the question because I loved
you know we've decided to go straight on
this show the true answer is I'd go in
and on it that's what I do so as close
as I am working with the Jets as a
client watching every play staying on
top of it there's still nuances that are
just not you know known to me
you know I think one thing I would do
for example if I bought the Jets today I
would mandate from the top and this
would probably make it a little harder
to get a GM and so that's something I'd
have to quantify but I would mandate
that we draft a quarterback every two
years in the first two rounds of the NFL
Draft until we had our guy right so like
I think it's a quarterback league the
rules go in that way and you have to
reverse engineer the league and so for
example right now I would draft the
quarterback in round one or two this
year because though I've given you know
the benefit of doubt he's clearly not
the overwhelming this is Andrew Luck
sitting in our pocket so we have to
draft another quarterback and if it's
not politically correct to Gino and his
agents or to the New York media or the
fan base I wouldn't care because I would
dictate to victory and I think that's
the right strategy right now in the NFL
if you do not have a quarterback first
two rounds you draft one you bring them
in if you don't feel good about I give
it I'd give it 24 months but after full
24 months after second season of that
player by the way whether he played a
snap or not I would draft another one
and another one and another one until I
had one because that is the linchpin I'd
also work on the PR team I would do a
weekly show livestream show with the fan
base so they could pound me with all
their angers and I pound them back
because that's the kind of owner I'd be
I would do a bunch of marketing things
you've heard me in the past that sent a
jersey of a Jets jersey to every
six-year-old in the tri-state area on
their sixth birthday I would probably do
a ton of inappropriate things at this
point there's you know like get into it
with the media because I think they're
out of their mind but the way they're
handling Jets in this Giants City
I would like watch the game from the
stands which I think would be an
interesting new thing but that would be
tough because I curse that opponents and
the NFL would try to reel me in so what
are some of the things I'd be doing Evan
asks if you could clone yourself would
you Evan this is a tremendous question
and a great one to end the year
especially because I announced that I'm
going away with my family for two weeks
this is easy of question as they've come
I would 100% mean this is the bat I
really wish this technology existed
because I would take that person
Gary to who is actually Gary to the
clone version anyway I would take the
cloned version and I would make that
person spend every waking moment with my
family and said home you guys what's
that why is that funny
what's that oh you oh I don't care keep
this keep this rolling by the way first
of all no no editing here you know I
don't think you understand the the fact
that matter is is they're the same
person
are you saying that from Alyssa maybe
that was an insight that we didn't maybe
I love my business more than my favor
sorry it's a tough way to end the show
and the year the bottom line is starting
that d-roc has become the cynical one
but Steve the bat and the torch has been
passed I would take the equal version of
it and have that person sit at home
every minute and be with my family
because then I would be able to
accomplish the two things that I want at
one time and so that would be the answer
question of the day how much do you hate
d-roc you keep asking questions I'll
keep answering everybody welcome to 58
crap wait subscribe I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe